u.s military running low on ammo after
arming ukraine pentagon officials are
concerned that the u.s ammunition stocks
donated to ukraine have severely
depleted u.s stocks
weakening u.s readiness in the event of
conflict the wall street journal
reported monday the biden administration
has drawn much of the 13 billion dollars
in weapon systems and accompanying
ammunition the u.s has provided to
ukraine from existing arsenals according
to the wall street journal while the
department of defense has declined to
disclose a number of ammunition rounds
in storage at the beginning of 2022
before the war in ukraine began it has
taken few steps to replenish depleting
stocks sparking worries that the us may
not have the ammunition it needs to
uh for its own protection the level of
155 millimeter combat rounds filed fired
by
uh howitzer weapon system in u.s
stockpiles has uh become
uncomfortably low a u.s pentagon
official told wall street journal the
uss sent 806 000 rounds
of the 100 pound explosive to ukraine as
of august 24th it's not at the level we
would like to go into combat the defense
official told wall street journal
uh uh uh supplied howitzer have extended
you uh used for ukrainian forces terms
of the foxes okay so there you have it
that was the story what you were talking
about i would say i'd say why don't we
go to afghanistan and get what we left
behind but i mean we're going to borrow
it back from al qaeda because now
they're you know taliban
whatever hey potatoes tomatoes whatever
potatoes potatoes tomatoes by the way
for people that don't know your
background when you were in the airports
you were working at a nuclear why don't
you tell everybody what you were i was
stationed at mountain from air force
base montana nuclear missile base i was
a flight security controller and truck
whenever i was on shift i was in charge
of 10 10 missiles that had up to five
warheads on each missile so i was the
guy that would
authenticate the guys going the missiles
the launchers authenticate them to go
downstairs they're the ones that get the
codes they're the ones that could launch
we had um 200 missiles at my base that
from what i heard from one of these guys
we could have blown up the world like 20
30 times over and i'm like why do we
have so much it's just it's insane but
but i saw pacquiao sometimes i worked
security where they'd open up the rail
and mind you 18 year old
airmen down there
working on a nuke and you look down and
you see it and it was just it was just
insane yeah 18 year old kid just like
this hey give me a sandwich oh my god
but it was scary and then and then they
just told me because you know i had to
have you know sacred clearance but and
he was like listen we have a couple of
these bases that's nothing he goes 80 of
our arsenal is just in the water just
swimming around and all these subs so if
[ __ ] never pops i mean that's why these
rounds it ain't that important because
we got other we got other stuff that we
could use you know yeah if you uh if you
want to sleep easy tonight know that
vinnie o'shanna is had his hand on the
nuclear button at any given moment
i couldn't go near the button but i was
making sure that they could okay what i
mean
i want to know who you bribed to get the
clearance no no oh you want to trip out
you want to drip out so i'm on leave i
go home to see my mom and my dad and
everybody and my my fifth grade math
teacher mr bonaparte because you know
when you get the clearance they're
asking people he sees me in the mall
he's like hey oh sean he's a huge huge
big a buff guy he goes dude you never
what are you doing in the military i was
like what do you mean he's like somebody
in the from the government called me and
said and i quote
does that he seem like the type of kid
that would grow up to do something
terrorist like [ __ ] to the country and
he was like no he was you know giving
people's wedgies and climbing up trees
and [ __ ] but no he wouldn't like blow
people up they're like all right thank
you click and that
fifth grade math teacher said that
somebody called him and asked him if
i'll if i turn into to be a maniac i
mean i am a maniac but yeah i would
never hurt the country
so
thank you for your service right okay
i wish i was recruited by the the guy
that was here the cia agent i'd be a
great cia
come on
i don't think you could blend in well
enough what are you nuts i'm a comedian
i'm out there i work here like what he
said the key is to not not be noticed
you are yeah
yeah if there's anything that you should
know about rob gargiulo not noticeable
not at all is he even is he here but by
the way but here's a good news sitting
right here good news even though
we are depleting and all this weapon
good news we have 87 000 irs agents
which is they'll save us
which is fine
they know how to use a gun yeah you saw
them you saw how they were that video
was sold for you that is a great
callback we have comedy
safe about this entire situation it's
not going to work
right on the front lines the average
american really knew what we've got yeah
they blow their mind yeah lasers so
let's let's skip
the
by the way the real
the real pitbull of the emir of the
world
military is the american navy and most
people don't know it and they think well
wait a minute you get the ship out there
get hit by a missile and everything you
have no idea the umbrella protections
over those ships
and you have no idea about the nuclear
subs and what they're doing down
underneath
but norad yeah norad is scary the stuff
that's under south dakota and montana
specifically and remember ellsworth air
force base elsewhere where all the b-52s
were and then tom daschle tried to close
it yep and then the voters closed his
career and they were done exactly that's
right bethune yeah
there's one there's my not air force
base there's one in um wisconsin there's
do we got nuclear bases well not just
that i think you could take the american
people can take some solace in the fact
that that the united states government
as as much as it's bloated and
um unefficient and those kinds of things
like you see you know it costs 94
billion dollars for nasa to produce a
rocket etc etc the us military produced
and built and designed a
sixth generation
uh airplane complete with ai like in
under a year brand new airplane brand
new airflame all new electronics all new
ai basically flies itself all in under a
year like we we if we want to do
something we can do it we still have the
best engineers in the world we still
have the best factories in the world
like we still can do these things but
the va forget it i went to the va and it
was the worst experience of my life
because i tore my legs so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
you